there's a smoking hot babe out the top
I'm in legend has it there's a smokin
hot babe at the time you have heard
their legend - yes big nose Maine I've
heard so you're gonna get tad babe right
yeah I'm gonna get that babe
go on then catch up there all right
how do I jump okay cause I choose which
direction I want to jump all right doing
good
[Music]
I got a jump from here we're in the
red-crowned woods so this no okay
this game is popular with streamers
because streamers are actual man
children who are not good at games even
though they play it every single day so
I thought hey look at that
oh my I don't want to go that direction
she must really be something it's all
about trajectories I know that's hard
for people to understand simple math and
trigonometry for me however comes quite
natural
I think I'll stay down no get up there
jump inside her nothing
I just need to learn game mechanics it's
fine look at that oh I know how shut up
I'm looking at like how bad I can see
under her skirt from here all right
let's do this jump shut up all right
it's okay I'm getting better I know
everyone scientists will study this
video how he gets good so fast that's
what they will say bruh I look like I
only do leg day look at these legs dude
that's amazing this is actually how I do
look when I do put on my legs fools
alright it's a quick jump hey look at
that almost there we go and a super jump
alright super jump
game looks so easy when you see other
people to play hey get up there okay
don't do too hard
yeah checkpoint
stop oh that was smooth okay fine
unbothered you see this face face that
don't care good job Felix damn good all
right same thing how do I get up there
now I'm gonna wait I'm gonna check out
here first okay
yes all right here we go I got a super
jump it nice Oh God
checkpoint please I made it to the
second area hey bird hey bird let me hug
you
no all right come on bird
I gotta start it from here right yeah
what's up bird out of my way huh
oh god I didn't even meet that was
amazing of course I meant to do that
what is up here how am I supposed to go
there you know they found an annoying
game but they also found the greatest
reward of all time oh babe ah ah hot
babe on top pop it on top all right here
we go watch me today hey put it on okay
all right this is a tricky one too but
I'm just that good I'm just that good
you ever not want to get up not me
always gets back up fine no it begins
the town the world's no the down
you oh my god one tiny mistake and by L
Mike stop yeah we're back in biz back in
bathe in the wall jump here watch this
oh my god stop how did the hot baby get
up there anyway no
there better be a hot babe I swear to
God at this if I've been trapped
stop ma this is this father's as I've
gone I think I have to super jump here
so maybe from here we have to super jump
ok alright got it
yeah alright there's hope I didn't see
the platform no unbothered
oh and we're back
three hours later stop I think I have to
stand here oh okay okay
no okay how do I do it how do I come on
bird come on bird here we go
come on look at me look at me yeah all
right all right I never made it this far
huh
what there's a guest on whoa colossal
drain easy easy
huh checkpoint all right watch this jump
I'm not taking any chances
it's fine I don't actually get mad watch
this jump or system no no no you think
I'm angry I have never been angry in my
life oh stop over back in the beginning
easy
stop stop oh my god just I want to get
up back where I was at leaves come back
baby come back he's back yeah yesterday
Smith she lied and what should these oh
and watch this and watch this Oh Tony's
on oh it's fine I just got to get back
to that platform no I will get laid
literally a game for in cells isn't it
Jesus Christ all right this one is a
little tricky it's a little tricky easy
[Music]
[ __ ] off you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] I
hope you die this tree makes no sense by
the way it's flowing in the front air
how do I do this all right what the hell
did I do last time
I'm so confused okay go go go go go go
Dorner poka poka poka poka no booger wha
ah ogo ogo ogo Pogo that jump stinks I
can smell it from a mile away a mile
yeah yeah yeah yeah
Berta throw these on hook [ __ ] [ __ ] I
want mo good I got hoes [ __ ] like I got
bit
what up the same yeah alright sign
[Music]
MNM out of victims Japan stop what ha
bogum
huh yes you shove a you shove it come
yet call me yet Oh bah gah bah gah no
thank you brainless piece of [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] oh great now I got to do all
this [ __ ] again
stop it stop no what there's a hat
there was a hat I want it yeah yeah I
got a hat I got a hat yeah yeah I got a
ham yeah it's worth it every time you
can't touch me because I'm already
broken inside you can't stop I feel like
I can do this yes
Sugoi Sugoi for fun so no oh still
waiting for that checkpoint jot that up
that was good that was really [ __ ]
good Felix try that again
you thought that would give over you
thought I give up for game yeah oh god
that looks really cheap smash like
subscribe I don't care about the hot
babe I don't care I don't care I'm
married I'm married I don't care about
the hot babe I don't care about the hug
babe
don't care
[Music]
now you are entering a new era where you
shall craft the whole poop
the hour of our spells and poop graces
coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need you
[Music]
the diaper you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne where T is the game to play
I'm not supposed to have my opinion
about that but the prices
you